mein name ist fritz ihrer hatschi ich
bin 1979 in münchen geboren
die chinesische regierung beschuldigte
sie eine terroristin zu sein
im juli 2017 wurde ich in ein lager
gesteckt ich hatte kasachstan besucht
und sie sagten sie müssten jetzt meine
gedanken reinigen
die wären vergiftet kasachstan sei ein
terroristischer start
mein name ist güllner im irak ich bin
nach kasachstan geflohen
in den lagern von ginger zwingen sie die
frauen zu verhüten und sich
sterilisieren zu lassen
die frauen bekommen verhütungsmittel
zwangsweise eingesetzt ich habe das
erlebt musste eine strafe für unser
drittes kind zahlen
danach wurde ich gegen meinen willen
sterilisiert für chinas machthaber gibt
es die geschichten dieser frau nicht so
wie es nicht die
menschenrechtsverletzungen an den
muslimischen minderheiten in der provinz
ziehen schon gibt sowie arbeitslager und
folter nicht existieren
die behauptungen in münchen sang finde
ein völkermord stadt ist lächerlich
das ist ein erfundenes gerücht das ist
eine glatte lüge
wer der wahrheit auf die spur kommen
will wie es den muslimischen
minderheiten in shenyang er geht der
muss in den nachbarstaat kasachstan
reisen in den abgelegenen bergregionen
leben die opfer die vor chinas
unterdrückungssystem geflohen sind
frauen wie grüner im sack ihr schicksal
belegt das leiden vieler in den lagern
sie redet mit uns damit die welt nicht
wegschaut
[Musik]
die chinesen unternehmen alles damit die
welt nichts von ihren taten in den
lagern erfährt dort löschen sie die
sprache der minderheiten aus china zeigt
dagegen eine heile welt kulturen und
kasachen tanzen und studieren fröhlich
die propaganda läuft auf hochtouren
seitdem der westen pekings machthaber
auf die anklagebank gesetzt hat grüne im
märz sagt dagegen ist eine zeuge
sie hat chinas versuch erlebt ihre
kultur und sprache auszuwischen
unsere kinder lernen ihre muttersprache
nicht
sie kennen die eigene kultur und
mentalität nicht in den
umerziehungslager werden nur die
chinesische sprache und die politik von
parteichef shipping beigebracht die
menschen werden gefoltert satelliten
fotos von john belegen dass immer mehr
lager gebaut werden gleichzeitig
verschwinden moscheen chinas
menschenrechtsverletzungen hinterlassen
spuren
seine forschungsarbeit haben chinas
verbrechen an den muslimischen
minderheiten aufgedeckt adrian sense hat
tausende von offiziellen dokumenten der
behörden in china durchforstet ohne die
untersuchungen des china-experten wusste
die welt wohl nichts von den
lagersystemen
wenn man sich dann auch budget daten
anschaut berichte satellitenaufnahmen
usw ist meine schätzung dass mindestens
knapp eine million maximal bis zu
womöglich 1,8 millionen per minderheiten
aktuell oder insgesamt in diesen lagern
waren die chinesische regierung
verhindert jegliche unabhängige
berichterstattung in john mit polizei
gewalt bezichtigt aber gleichzeitig die
westlichen medien der lüge
zuletzt ist dies dem englischen sender
bbc mit einem bericht über zwangsarbeit
passiert das chinesische staatsfernsehen
stellte den sender und dessen reporter
an den pranger
das sind fake news bbc verdreht die
fakten
dann zeigen sie die fabrik von innen
eine heile welt die chinesische
reporterin umarmt die arbeiterin die
erklärt sie sei freiwillig hier
sie war mehrere monate in einem
umerziehungslager eingesperrt erlebte
einen alptraum der permanenten
überwachung
wir durften nur zweimal am tag auf die
toilette jede frau hatte nur zwei
minuten zeit wenn wir länger brauchten
dann würden wir mit einem knüppel
geschlagen
[Musik]
kulterer hanka sie zeigt ihre videos
ergic anbieters er half ihr und ihrer
familie china zu verlassen
gegen das leid der muslime zu kämpfen
ist die lebensaufgabe von särge stabiler
geworden seine arbeit brachte ihn schon
damals in gefahr
sechs monate nach unserem ersten treffen
wollen wir wieder kontakt mit bilanz
aufnehmen er lebt jetzt in den usa
er will nicht dass wir seinen genauen
aufenthaltsort preisgeben der mann der
tausenden von frauen geholfen hat ist
selber ein verfolgter geworden
china hat seine wirtschaftliche macht
eingesetzt um sein heimatland kasachstan
unter druck zu setzen gegen biel es
etwas zu unternehmen
kasachstan muss den befehl von peking
folgen
das land ist quasi eine provinz von
china geworden
es verliert mehr und mehr seine
unabhängigkeit der spielplatz vor seiner
tür erinnert ihn an seine drei kinder
und seine frau die aus
sicherheitsgründen getrennt von ihm lebe
in kasachstan bekam sie morddrohungen er
sollte zum schweigen gebracht werden
sie sagten vielleicht hast du einen
schlimmen autounfall und du und deine
familie sterben
sie haben das brutal klar gemacht ich
weiß dass die die mich bedrohten für den
kasachischen geheimdienst arbeiteten
wer china kritisiert wird verfolgt und
zahlt einen hohen preis
trotzdem sehr geschah will weiter
versuchen seinen landsleuten zu helfen
aber erst einmal ist aus dem
fluchthelfer ein flüchtling geworden